oui avec le téléphone on est comme ça
alors du coup est-ce que tu peux juste
me redonner ton nom et ton prénom
Régis
[Musique]
pour le particulier pour les
automatismes
en 2008
avec la participation du Conseil Général
qu'est-ce que tu as apporté alors cette
victoire au challenge et créateur
beaucoup de
je dirais d'assurance le fait d'être
venu d'avoir
je crois qu'on était 30 candidats au
départ donc d'être passé devant un jury
d'avoir
présenté un projet de l'avoir défendu de
l'avoir d'avoir expliqué un peu à
l'époque à la naissance du projet ce
qu'on voulait faire
à ce moment précis c'est vraiment très
important où ça vaut vraiment de
l'assurance pour la suite le fait après
d'être retenu parmi les quatre
finalistes c'était que du que du que du
plus et tu termines 3e en 2008 j'avais
reçu un chèque de 3100 euros du conseil
général qui a mis du beurre dans les
épinards ça
à ces moments là on a toujours besoin de
de d'acheter d'investir et pour la suite
c'est vraiment enfin c'est quelque chose
qui me suit jusqu'à jusqu'à
jusqu'aujourd'hui
et
une grosse fierté d'être passé par la
voix d'une séance des jeunes créateurs
OK et maintenant est-ce que tu peux me
dire où en est ton entreprise est-ce que
ça fonctionne les actualités du moment
très bien j'ai commencé tout seul
donc j'ai des technicien j'allais faire
les chantiers je faisais des devis je
faisais le commercial je faisais tout de
A à Z
l'activité était en croissante donc j'ai
embauché une
assistante une secrétaire après un
technicien après
quelques années plus tard un apprenti à
notre technicien aujourd'hui
beep pro présente cette salariés
moi le commercial on est deux des
indépendants donc on est à 9 et on fait
vivre indirectement trois sous-traitants
ok super et juste pour
finir donner ce dont toi les principales
qualités qu'il faut avoir pour créer son
entreprise
qualité principale je pense que du
courage il faut y aller faut vraiment se
lancer il faut oser parce que beaucoup
de personnes ont beaucoup de jeunes ont
des ont des bonnes idées
qui pourraient qui pourrait marcher mais
si on n'a pas cette motivation et cette
envie de de le faire tout simplement ça
peut pas marcher voilà super bah écoute